globetrotter darm spezialist für
maßgeschneiderte rat gibt globetrotter
punkt ch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin im norden indiens angekommen
im bundesstaat assam hierher verirrt
sich kaum je ein lästiger tourist wir
sind am ufer des kama potsdam ist ein
schmelztiegel verschiedener kulturen und
einflüsse die meisten menschen die
erleben sind hindu
schildger borderline ist meine reise
gefährtin und übersetzerin zusammen
besteigen die fähre nach machule island
einer riesigen insel mitten im fluss
[Musik]
unsere reise startet enkelin im süden
chinas
wir folgten der ort burma myanmar dem
früheren birma über manderlay erreichten
die yang gon
jetzt sind wir dennoch linken in assam
besuchen wir machule island der fluss
brahmaputra mäandert hier durch die
landschaft an einigen stellen ist er bis
zu 10 km breit
der fluss verändert die landschaft
ständig
spitz darauf firma butter auf dem
heiligen fluss mit 27 oder sogar uta
einer der längsten flüsse der welt
er entspringt im himalaya-gebirge fuß
durch lieder und dahingehend schon ab
und sorge für hunderte sind informanten
in der mitte von butter liegt die größte
flussinsel der welt
juli island und wäre auf der insel will
dem austria auf den fähren zwischen
machule island und dem festland gibt es
nie genügend platz für die bewohner des
festlands ist nocioni ausflugsziel und
pilgerort die bewohner machule ist
fahren aufs festland um zu arbeiten
beim aussteigen herrscht dass der stress
willkommen in indien die öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel sind oft überfüllt
schild ist ausgebildete tänzerin sie
kennt ward schule island gut sie hat
hier schon öfter für kulturprojekte
gearbeitet
wir fahren zu unserem ersten treffen
[Musik]
die insulin ist noch 420
quadratkilometer
die erosion ließ die insel bereits um
zwei drittel schrumpfen
so verlieren die menschen hier immer
mehr von ihrer lebensgrundlage erklärt
der chemiker
während der regenzeit ist hier alles
überflutet
ab juli juli august
was geschieht mit den menschen hier
das sind alles provisorische häuser
während der regenzeit kommen die leute
hier herauf leben auf der straße und
nach ungefähr zehn tagen wenn der regen
aufhört gehen sie zurück und
restaurieren ihre häuser
war julie hyland ist zwar bedroht aber
die landschaft ist idyllisch und
fruchtbar reis wechselt sich ab mit
wasserhyazinthen schill kicker und ich
treffen kolja calida bis vor einigen
jahren war er bauer calida dachte dass
sich bothe gut verkaufen lassen
während der regenzeit ist man auf der
insel mit dem boot unterwegs aber holz
ist knapp und darum teuer
die menschen hier können sich ein neues
bot kaum leisten
nur die armen sind ja auf der insel
geblieben und kämpfen ums überleben
der arbeit gefunden hat oder gute
geschäfte gemacht hat ist längst nur die
armen bleiben zurück auch khalid dass
frau trägt zum einkommen bei sie stellt
krüge aus lehm her so wie sie hier in
jedem haus verwendet werden
[Musik]
wir haben viele probleme wegen der
erosion den lehman für die töpfe nehmen
wir aus der er land wenn das nicht mehr
möglich ist verschwindet auch unsere
lebensgrundlage und wir haben kein
einkommen mehr
die krüge werden aufs festland
transportiert und dort auf dem markt
verkauft
allen die hier leben macht die
fortschreitende erosion der insel zu
schaffen
carlita nennt uns die gründe der
bootsverkehr der wellen verursacht die
klimaveränderung mit den immer stärkeren
konsum und die staudämme die weiter oben
in den fluss gebaut worden
die folgen sind verheerend das dorf in
dem fall etat gewohnt dafür wurde von
den fluten mitgerissen
können sie uns zeigen wo sie gelebt
haben
ungefähr eine meile von ihr dort drüben
waren so drauf jetzt ist es vollkommen
vom schloss über steckt
ich kann nicht mal mehr genau zeigen wo
es war der boden rutschte einfach weg
geht die erosion in diesem tempo weiter
existiert die insel in 20 jahren nicht
mehr sagen experten
während der regenzeit fährt calida mit
dem boot bis zum haus hier lebt er mit
seiner frau und den zwei söhnen die
sollen später mal einen guten job auf
dem festland finden hoffen die eltern
die einrichtung im haus ist spärlich
nicht nur wegen der armut
das wasser fließt in der regenzeit ins
haus erzählt karina dann müssten sie
sich da oben ein richten caritas frau
zeigt uns die leiter auf der sie ins
obergeschoss klettern
sie ist das bambus hier oben finden sie
zuflucht vor dem wasser die zukunft ist
ungewiss
und doch kämpfen die menschen hier um
ihre insel wallbott juli ihre heimat ist
wer morgen bricht an geschlafen habe ich
in einem der wenigen gasthäuser auf der
insel
der tourismus entwickelt sich hier nur
langsam und ist noch ausbaufähig
danke für das heiße wasser perfekt ist
auch diesmal braucht die durchqueren die
insel
heute ist unser ziel ein kloster ein
sogenanntes atra vor 20 jahren gab es
auf der insel noch 60 davon
heute sind es noch gut 20 schiffe karine
jenes zeigen indem sie mit jungen
münchen ein tanzprojekt erarbeitet hat
[Musik]
die mönche sind die hüter einer langen
tradition
viele buchen werden oft schon als
sechsjährige ans kloster weg gegeben
von ihren eltern die glauben damit
dennoch zu gefallen
[Musik]
jeder knabe bekommt einen älteren
möglich als mentor zur seite
er ist für seine erziehung zuständig im
gegenzug sollten die jungen für ihre
mentorin wenn diese auf sind
die buben wachsenden kloster auf und
verbringen hier ihr leben die sei eine
ehre werden gesagt auch der vorsteher
wurde als zehnjähriger hierher gebracht
wir schauen uns die buben in den dörfern
ab erkundigen wir uns bei den eltern wie
sie lernen und sich verhalten
sie sollen natürlich auch gut aussehen
weil sie ja tanzen und auftreten müssen
so ist den ich beim tanzen gesehen habe
besucht die schule im dorf im kloster
lernt er wie alle hier sonst kriegt und
tanz ungefragt führte uns ein paar
kunststücke vor für mich eine schwer
durchschaubare welt wir wollen wissen
was die buchen über das leben im kloster
denken
wie findest du es hier ich weiß nicht
wie ist das leben hier für dich ich
meine eltern fragen ob es mir gefällt
und was ich gelernt habe und wir in
ihren sie wenn du ihnen zeigt was er
gelernt hast
sie freuen sich sehr dass ich so viel
lerne sie sind also zufrieden ja sind
sie stolz ja
ein paar mal im jahr dürfen die buben
nach hause aber ihr platz ist hier in
der männergemeinschaft bis zum tod
nicht nur die religion auch die armut
treibt menschen wo dazu einen sohn
wegzugeben denke ich mir beim abschied
[Musik]
die fähre bringt uns zurück aufs
festland
[Musik]
ich will wissen wo und wie es ohne
untergang von schulen und ich habe
lieber die klappe fällt trotz mädchen
brutal und unfair ihre mannschaft da
sich aber für niemand oder weniger
großen stromerzeuger 200 000 türken
anzumerken versorgen und jetzt gehts
lösung für die mannschaft ein ende hat
er sogenannte boat klinik ist das
mittlerweile 15 eine burg zu fahren und
den manche medizinische vorsorge
strähnen
doktor die ori leitet das medizinische
team die nächsten tage werden sie
zusammen auf der schwimmenden
krankenstation verbringen
das schiff heißt acker hoffnung
tatsächlich brauchte seinen erfahrenen
kapitän wenn das boot durch den
brahmaputra fährt fast täglich ändert
der fluss seinen lauf und das ist
türkisch aber doktor theorie hat eine
mission
wir fahren vier mal pro monat in die
dörfer sind immer drei bis vier tage
unterwegs im durchschnitt behandeln wir
rund 100 personen pro tag rund 15.000
menschen in der schiffs kombüse ist es
zwar eng aber es findet sich alles was
es für ein paar tage braucht mit dabei
sind eine hebamme ein apotheker
gemeindearbeiter und pflegefachfrauen
eine klingt ihr baby nicht
es ist jedes mal eine große
herausforderung weil die menschen da
draußen nicht gut versorgt sind
unsere hauptaufgabe ist im moment die
kinder zu impfen und die hohe
kindersterblichkeit zu bekämpfen
leider sterben auch immer noch zu viele
mütter bei der geburt fünf stunden
dauert die fahrt dann haben wir das ziel
erreicht das team besucht ein dorf vom
stamm der mischung die mischung
minderheit hat eine ganz eigene kultur
in ihren traditionellen ritualen bringen
sieht ihr opfer dar und verehren wind
sonne und mond
die menschen hier haben großes vertrauen
in das medizinische personal von der
boot könig aber es käme wohl niemand
wenn die behandlung nicht kostenlos wäre
[Musik]
die älteren mischung sind meist
analphabeten sie müssen gut instruiert
werden
viele kinder leiden unter den folgen von
verschmutztem wasser und ungenügender
hygiene fast alle hier haben durchfall
und fieber
auch diese kleine leidet unter starkem
durchfall bei der ersten geburt sind
wird er oft noch sehr jung wie diese
patientin noch immer ist sie völlig
entkräftet viele sterben bei der geburt
ihres kindes
[Musik]
ich habe heute 20 impfungen gemacht
mannes 20.10 nachgeburt untersuchungen
diverse tests zum glück gab es heute
keine schlimmen fälle vor einbruch der
nacht beeilen sich die frauen in die
dörfer zurückzukehren
morgen wird das team von dr dre weiter
zur nächsten insel wo neue patienten
warten
am folgenden tag erreichen wird er hat
eine chaotische kleinstadt die einst das
zentrum des widerstands gegen die
britische kolonialherrschaft war
ich habe mit schild borderless vater
abgemacht wir wollen auf dem fischmarkt
für das nachtessen einkaufen
sie müssen schädigers vater sein
ja ja ich bin jesus an cordula schön sie
kennt werden ich bin barbara sie hat mir
viel von ihnen erzählt frau border
läufig am abend in die kunst der
indischen küche ein
den perfekten fisch auszusuchen ist die
aufgabe ihres mannes
er ist von hier kam barbara oder lebt er
noch
wie viel kostet der 800 kilo
ich denke 700 kilo ja gut sie können ich
könnte viel lernen
ja der fisch ist von ihr und ist noch am
leben also ganz frisch diesen hier
werden die auf- und ausfahrten
das ist in asien so unüblich aber daran
werde ich mich nie gewöhnen
herborn bringt schon mal den fisch nach
hause und ich besuche eine schule in
ausnahmen waren schulen bisher besonders
schlecht entwickelt aber jetzt heißt
verstaatliche zauberwort für den
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung der größten
demokratie der welt ausbildung
[Musik]
230 kinder besuchen die prima und
oberstufe ich bin an dieser schule die
erste ausländische besucherin
[Musik]
die schüler bezahlen für uniform und
bücher nichts viele eltern gegen selber
nie zur schule und sind analphabeten
wenn sie ihre kinder nicht zur schule
schicken wo ist die lehrerin diese
persönlich ab
wie überall auf der welt sie kinder
neugierig und wollen wissen wie ich
heiße das ist mein name ich heiße
barbara aber ich lebe in hongkong
lehrerin ramadi grund ist sehr engagiert
verdient aber wie alle lehrer in indien
sehr wenig viele kollegen haben einen
zweiten job und tauchen tagelang nicht
auf ihr aber gegen die kinder am herzen
die meisten schüler kommen aus armen
familien und werden zu hause kaum
kontrolliert viele leiden an
unterernährung
den eltern ist es auch egal ob sie
hausaufgaben machen
das ist für uns eine große
herausforderung wenn wir ein kind
ausbilden dann bilden wir immer auch die
ganze familie und somit die gesellschaft
aus so können wir viel bewirken
ben ali naht ist elf jahre alt sie ist
besonders fleißig und kann immer als
erster die frage der lehrerin
beantworten
wir fragen ob er sie nach hause
begleiten dürfen
jeden tag legt sie den einstündigen
schulweg zu fuß zurück ben ali lebt
während der woche mit ihrer mutter und
den zwei schwestern der vater arbeitet
auf dem bau und kommt nur am wochenende
heim
sie ist pflichtbewusst und macht gerne
hausaufgaben
ich lerne weil mein vater auch sehr hart
arbeitet und ich möchte dass er stolz
auf mich sein kann weil ich erfolg habe
die 11 jährige träumt davon polizistin
zu werden
dann würde sich so einiges ändern und
männer die ihre frauen schlagen
bestrafen
bei uns zu hause kommt das nicht vor
aber nebenan gibt es einen mann der wenn
er betrunken ist eine frau schlägt wenn
du als polizistin engelmann siehst wer
seine frau schlägt was würdest du tun
ich würde ihn verhaften dann würde ich
ihn fragen wieso er das tut wenn er
keinen guten grund hat würde ich ihn für
lange zeit ins gefängnis stecken
das traue ich ben ali ohne weiteres zu
aber hier im nordosten indiens in assam
lässt man viele mädchen gar keine
ausbildung machen sie werden schon sehr
früh mit 13 14 jahren verheiratet
dass ihre mutter ein wenig anders denkt
aus viele frauen im dorf
wenn sie einen guten mann auswählen dann
ist es okay aber viele männer sind nicht
gut
warum sollen sie nicht unbedingt
heiraten sondern versuchen
auf eigenen beinen zu stehen ich rate
ihnen natürlich keine affären zu haben
sie soll warten bis ein mann kommt und
um ihre hand anhält und wie alle mütter
der welt wünscht sie ihren drei töchtern
dass sie einfach glücklich werden noch
lange hätte ich mit den frauen über die
rolle in der indischen gesellschaft
reden mögen aber ich habe noch eine
verabredung in einem mittelklasse
quartier von show hat die mutter meiner
begleiterin chemiker will mich in die
kunst der englischen küche einführen das
es einen fisch mit wenigen geräten
man muss etwas kardamon stärke und salz
dazugeben
das schöne an der englischen küche sind
die vielen gewürzen ein löffel reicht
wir haben und ein wenig stärker
[Musik]
wer hat sie kochen gelehrt ja wir mögen
den hiesigen fluss fischer und diese
zubereitungsart habe ich von meiner
mutter gelernt
traditionelles rezept wenn sie zeit hat
um zu kochen dann bereitet sie den fisch
genauso zu und sie hat mir erzählt dass
es alle mögen
ich hoffe sie auch wirklich mehr ganz
sicher
lassen sie mich an
so sieht also tauben curry aus eine
besondere delikatesse fragt fraport dann
kommt schrieb die tochter dazu kannst du
val die rezepte kochen was mit dem tisch
ja das andere mit taube kann ich noch
nicht gut aus und das rezept gar nicht
so kompliziert
das letzte gericht gelöst ist der tisch
ist voller köstlichkeiten einmal mehr
weiß ich warum ich aussehen so liebe
wegen dem essen
vielen dank ich weiß ich sollte dich mit
der linken hand essen aber ich bin
linkshänderin ich kann nicht anders
die linke ist die unreine gegessen wird
nur mit der rechten hand bist du von dir
als köchin beeindruckt ja sehr
schmeckt sehr gut das habe ich sehr gute
viel probiert aber dann hat er ganz
viele andere gerichte die gastgeberin
wird erst essen wenn alle anderen am
tisch sind so gebietet es die
höflichkeit hier am ende habe ich mich
etwas über essen nicht zum letzten mal
in indien spätabends verabschiede ich
mich von schwitters herzlicher familie
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen am busbahnhof in show
hat hier soll er seinen bus zum
kassierer nationalpark bieten
fahren sie noch passieren
[Musik]
nein
das hier angeschlagen
sie fahren doch nach kuba rat die
kassierer ist auf dem weg
wichtige weitere stunden an der seite
stoppen
nach machu die island und torwart folge
ich immer noch dem heiligen fluss
brahmaputra ich reise 100 kilometer
westwärts bis zum kassier anker
nationalpark im bus kaufe ich eine
zeitschrift der erste akt ordentlich
lese handelt vergewaltigungen linien ein
großes thema in diesem land wo frauen
noch häufig als menschen zweiter klasse
behandelt werden
ich denke zurück kann die schülerin war
an alle die davon träumt der einst als
polizistin alle männer die frauen
schlecht behandeln zu bestrafen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
beim kassierer nationalpark hält der bus
tatsächlich nur für mich
wer park dem sich über 430
quadratkilometer aus er ist schutzgebiet
für zahlreiche tierarten seit über 100
jahren
[Musik]
berühmt ist er für das panzernashorn dem
horn puffer werden in china und
indonesien potenz steigende fähigkeiten
zugeschrieben
darum ist dieses nasa heute vom
aussterben bedroht sogar der shoah
bengal tiger lässt sich kurz blicken
von ihnen gibt es hier noch um die 80
der fotograf und tierschützer bass cover
ruhr hatte den banker schon mehrmals vor
der linse auch die elefanten kennt ihr
jetzt was die junge haben ist allerdings
ein sicherheitsabstand ratsam
elefanten haben eine beeindruckende
fähigkeiten miteinander zu kommunizieren
droht gefahr beten sie sofort ein
schutzschild für die babys und die
jungtiere
das cover ruhr kennt auch die
parkwächter hier ihr gewehr ist für die
selbstverteidigung gedacht aber ab und
zu müssen sie es auch gegen wilderer
einsetzen
genau das passierte vor ein paar wochen
locker hat carrey auch ihr ist
parkwächter und patrouillierte mit
seinem elefanten dabei ertappte lockt
laut einen nashorn wilderer auf frischer
tat als dieser mit den geraubten horn
davonrennen wollte machte lohan hat
kurzen prozess
ich bin vom elefanten gestiegen aber die
waffe geladen und gerufen er solle
stehen bleiben weil er weiter gerannt
ist habe ich ihn erschossen
[Musik]
loggt er sei stolz darauf
ich habe gemischte gefühle
ich bin stolz auf ihn aber ich habe auch
immer angst wenn er zur arbeit in den
park geht
die beiden haben ein zweijähriges
mädchen auch seinetwegen ist die 16
jährige bieler froh dass die tötung
nicht geahndet wurde
im gegenteil von einer
nichtregierungsorganisation bekam lockt
sogar eine prämie
davon kaufte er ein bild
loks zukunft ist ungewiss
er weiß nie wie lange er seinen job noch
hat den festanstellungen gibt es hier
kaum ein parkwächter verdient gerade mal
70 franken im monat
tierschützer tosca barrois weiß das
nashorn händler für einhorn bis zu 5000
franken bieten
dieser versuchung kann nicht jeder
widerstehen
im kasseler park gibt es noch gut 2000
panzernashörner das sind 70 prozent des
weltweiten bestandes immer wieder mal
laufen in die dickhäuter über den weg
nach einer scharfen kurve sah ich
plötzlich diese günstigen eines jagte
das andere
das ist das weibchen und das ist das
männchen
ich filmte sie aber ich hatte angst und
eines kam immer näher
das einzige was uns rettet er war dass
ich zurück fuhr und hupte zum glück
entschieden die tiere dass es nun reicht
und die waren in sicherheit
aber das war ziemlich knapp
der park gehört seit 1980 zum
weltnaturerbe der unesco
560 verschiedene vogelarten haben sich
hier angesiedelt
aber auch andere tiere finden sich hier
zu hause
[Musik]
ich mache mich wieder auf die reise
hinauf in die berge richtung darjeeling
2000 meter über meer
der nächste hat ist cool und dann vom
kassierer nationalpark reise ich nach
darjeeling nach china das zweitgrößte
anbaugebiet der welt
[Musik]
inkoom steige ich in den alten dampfzug
mit ihm fahre ich in die telefone nach
darjeeling die engländer brachten hier
her als sie die gegen das schuljahr
sommerresidenz in beschlag nahmen und
der hitze kattas zu entfliehen
bis heute wird der zug gut genutzt die
einwohner fahren mit ihm zur arbeit die
touristen lieben seine nostalgie
[Musik]
davor war ich perfekt gelaufen haben am
schluss die ganze hofstaat
[Musik]
dann erreichen wir dazu
der schilling ist ein morgendliches
versprechen in der europäischen teetasse
die stadt zieht indische und westliche
touristen gleichermaßen an
aber auch migranten aus dem nahen nepal
oder tibet die erinnerung an die
engländer zerfällt langsam
von hier aus starteten die expeditionen
ins himalaya-gebirge und hier wohnte
einer der berühmtesten sherpas der welt
es ist die steilen aufstieg zum
traurigen orgien sohn vom 10 10 oder im
wald oriente schärfer zusammen mit dem
soeben und hillary aus erste spritze wo
man den rest geschafft hat hallo ich bin
barbara guten tag kommen sie rein
das ist erstaunlich ein ja ein privates
museum
[Musik]
hier sind einige sammelstücke meines
vaters das ist privat nicht für die
öffentlichkeit
nein nur für freunde und familie
an der wand hängt das foto seines vaters
bei der erstbesteigung des mount everest
1953 zusammen
wie ist es denn das ganze leben im
schatten des vaters zu stehen ich bin
sehr stolz der sohn von tenzing norgay
schärfer zu sein
wer kann von sich behaupten der sohn
einer solchen persönlichkeit zu sein
ich glaube es ist mein karma mein
schicksal in diese familie hineingeboren
worden zu sein
ich habe nicht das gefühl im schatten zu
stehen
ich bin sogar stolz mit einem so
legendären bescheidenen mann verband zu
sein
ihr vater wollte ja der sein ganzes
leben
er hat uns davon abgehalten in dem er
uns nicht ermutigt zu klettern
er sah klettern immer als einen beruf an
als etwas wo er uns nicht haben wollte
weil es gefährlich
er sagte er klettere damit wir nicht
müssten
er schickte uns weg in die besten
schulen da die links und den die
vereinigten staaten jumping norgay
arbeitet heute als coach aber einmal
1996 besteht auch er den berg der berge
im andenken an seinen vater für mich war
das wie eine art wallfahrt die pilgerte
auf seinem berg als hommage an ihn indem
ich genau dasselbe wie er machte kam er
mir natürlich nicht mit seiner
ausrüstung das wäre heute unmöglich
um ein haar hätte sein vater die
schweizer expedition als erste auf den
gipfel geführt das schweizer team hat
das 1952 zwei mal versucht sie kamen bis
400 meter vor dem gipfel mit renault
sie waren die besten freunde meines
vaters kletter kollegen die er sehr
mochte er bedauerte es sehr dass sie es
nicht bis nach oben schafft
er liebte sie waren wie blutsbrüder die
schweiz war seine zweite heimat
er war oft dort bei seinen freunden
obwohl er seinen eigenen weg gefunden
hat kann seine gedanken immer wieder zu
seinem vater
in der nächsten und letzten folge
besuche ich die wohl berühmtesten t
berge der welt dort schilling
ich lerne man war chart erkennen er hat
einen der härtesten jobs der welt und
ich bin zu gast bei einer bravourösen
bengalischen hochzeit mit viel gold und
pop
[Musik]
rot-rot mit globetrotter und
fernsehfestival siebte bis achte
november im kursaal bern fernsehfestival
punkt ch